[Music]
let's go to joe in
clayton california hey what's up joe
hey john how are you good brother how
are we doing
pretty good good deal taking my call
yeah man what's up how can i help
okay so my question is how do i support
my wife emotionally while we're going
through
her fertility treatment
so
a little back story on this about three
years ago she had a early um
uh can you think of the name right now
i'm sorry i got a little nervous no
that's all good uh miss carrick um
miscarriage yes sorry i couldn't think
of the word and then so we went through
that you know a little difficult time
and then
about a year in we started seeing some
doctors because uh
we weren't having a baby and then
she did some medication
and now you know going forward we're
going through this now uh we did one iui
um as part of the doctor and that didn't
work out uh we're still waiting to hear
back on that
um but i just feel like lately
you know she's talking she works at a
hospital so lately all her co-workers
are getting pregnant it seems like on
social media that's all she's seen
and i just feel like
that's all we've been she's been
bringing up and talking and she's very
upset why can't i get pregnant and stuff
like that i just don't know how
to support her like emotionally going
through all this
um none of our close close friends have
any kids that have gone through this so
i don't feel like any of them have
helped or can help
i just don't know i feel like i'm
overwhelmed with this yeah man well
thank you so much and i can tell you
from personal experience i've done this
the wrong way on um in in in a pretty
dramatic fashion so
um i'm gonna tell you things i've
when i'm sitting with i've sat with
couples to talk about this and i'll tell
you
i'll mix it and match with my own
experience okay
um first
i dramatically
i missed i failed
i did not understand the scope of
devastation that a miscarriage
uh brought to my wife
a letter down
okay
so what i would tell you is however you
felt or didn't feel
multiply that by a thousand
the women i've met with over the last
decade who've experienced miscarriages
have said things like
i feel like my body is taking it's
killing babies i feel like my body
doesn't work properly i feel like i'm
failing as a woman like some really deep
powerful hard things
that are core to identity right really
tough stuff
and as a husband i was like i mean it's
just mother nature or it's just this or
it's just that completely missed it
okay right so
in those moments what i've learned to do
is to shut my mouth
and listen and not try to solve a thing
but to just be with
okay
okay the second thing is is i recommend
to every single couple going through
some sort of
infertility um
having that conversation the discussions
the hey this isn't happening as fast as
we thought
to go
spend some time together
having the conversation about how far
are we gonna go down this road
and what i mean by that is there is
always a doctor or a treatment facility
that will sell you any number of
different ideas or tricks or
opportunities
to the tune of
hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's right so for me and my wife when
we started we said we will not go
past line
x y and z
and for us it was we're not going to do
infertility stuff we're not going to go
through all we'll do you know basic
vitamins will do some
coach you know whatever
and it ended up working out for us but
we're not going to go through all these
other things
okay but we drew a line in the sand and
then we had to grieve the crap out of
that line
okay and this is where a lot of um
husbands don't get it
that
for us again i'm painting a broad
general brush here right this is not
everybody this is just a big generalized
picture
i started thinking about kids
like
after i was married for a while
like huh
it'd be cool to have like a little dude
like me running around like i had a
totally different picture um
my wife had pictures of
what her home would look like and the
kids running around in her home when she
was teeny like very very young little
girl
and so the the differences in how we
grieved
was dramatic and and big
and she
owned every inch of that and it's my job
as her husband to sit in that with her
if she'll even have me she may have to
sit in that by herself sometimes
okay
and you and or her
then you walk past that empty room
and you're imagining the nursery
you're imagining little trucks scattered
all over the
place and you go to somebody's room and
you see like at your friend's house and
they've got like a stack of diapers
somewhere
right
um every period is devastating have you
experienced that
um well
at first she did when we first got
married she didn't really want kids so
that's like the thing that kind of threw
me off that i feel like it's just
recently in the past three years
i don't know if maybe because she's
getting older what so let me let me tell
you this
whatever she said when y'all first got
married throw it out the window it
doesn't matter y'all are here now okay
right right and the more you try to be
like yeah but three years ago dude we're
here now you know we're here now um
and now she's telling you that
every time
she has a period
it's that her body's failed her again
right and something's wrong and quite
honestly there's a feeling that she's
failed you
and she's feeling this picture and this
family you know all those things right
yeah and that's what i've reassured her
you know that
i'm
it's not a make-a-break you know she's
always saying like you know
you would have made somebody else i
reassure her all the time like no
that's not the case that's right but i
mean that's one thing that she always
brings up
and there's also there's also
like i don't know if you ever lost like
a parent or a brother or sister or
somebody close to you but there's always
that
if i just called them they wouldn't have
got in the car
right there's always this replaying of
things that you can't change
right right and that's just part of
grief and so you doing the right thing
by reassuring and saying thank you
here's something that is not talked
about very often that is very fair
you have needs to
and you are allowed to say
i want to take 30 days off of talking
about babies
it's heavy in the home i feel like i'm
losing my wife and i know that you're
grieving
i am too
i want to take 30 days off from the baby
conversation
it's becoming overwhelming in the house
okay and you're allowed to have that
need also
yeah i think that's that's kind of what
i was
wanting to bring up but without seeming
unsensitive or trying to say you know
i don't want a kid you know what i mean
because i feel like she might take it to
that extreme no no no what i'm saying is
there's a difference between saying you
need to shut up or you need to get over
it that's insensitive
right
um
saying i'm hurting too
and every time you come home talking
about how everybody else has babies i
have to hear it i i can't hear it either
it hurts
i need a break
from talking about this can we stop
quote unquote trying to have a kid can
we give it 60 days two months and then
we'll reset
and
um
it may be a
here's another another angle to this
that i would recommend you take if you
haven't
already um i would ask that you and her
on your own alone
write a letter
to the baby that you lost
okay
did y'all name this kid
no
okay
um i have tattooed on my body three
babies that we lost in miscarriage
with names
okay
and i had to grieve them my wife grieved
them we grieved them together
as though we lost
a child that we were holding okay
it's a part of the grief it's part of
the grief cycle and
women are often told yeah it's cool man
we'll just try again
oh that sucks you know what i mean and
so they're what they're encouraged by
their community is to bury that grief
shove it down
just a miscarriage get over yourself
and so uh i'd recommend having some sort
of
small ceremony with just you too
okay okay and it's gonna be heavy it's
gonna be hard and it's gonna be
liberating
okay can i definitely try that
um if you bring that up
and say this is something you want to do
and you'd love her to join you that is a
totally different thing than telling her
hey i think you're probably going
through some grief and so probably help
if you see what i'm saying i want you to
take ownership of this okay okay right
okay ownership of i want to take 60 days
off in in the house i need this for me
because i'm hurting too i see i i hurt
when my wife hurts
let's take 60 days off from talking
about babies let's take 30 days off
whatever that looks like let's stop
trying we need to keep having sex right
we still do the fun part but we're gonna
stop quote-unquote trying to have babies
and following the clock and oh it's
three o'clock let's you know all that
kind of we're gonna stop that for 60
days
i need to get back to just being with my
wife
yeah and i think that's that's where
i feel like i'm getting overwhelmed with
that too because i work a ton of hours
i usually get home i wake up about two
in the morning and get home about 5 30
when it's just like you said it's that
we gotta do we gotta do this we gotta do
this and it seems like it's
like a second job yeah yeah yeah and
yes and at first you're like you can't
tell your buddies that because it's like
oh oh when when you mean every day at
five o'clock you have to have sex
yeah but it comes with a lot of pressure
and a lot of expectation a lot of
you get taken out of it right you become
a vessel for this
other picture right right and it's not
it's not something about can it's not
connection it's not something about you
know
people aren't even having fun anymore
it's about
a very clinical op like and it's just
yeah everybody said pause control delete
let's reset right right okay yeah um but
again hear me say real clearly
this is about you saying here's what i
need not here's what you should do
okay okay it may even help if you write
down
here's what i need and why because i'm
hurting i'm scared i'm sad
and by the way
it's not um
if she's saying you should have just
married somebody else i
i
if you're sad that you don't that she's
not pregnant that you haven't had a kid
yet it's okay to say that out loud
hiding from her or keeping that secret
from her is not helping your marriage
right yeah okay
and so be honest with her when you have
that um small little ceremony for that
baby
that she's still grieving even though
she thinks she's not she's still
grieving that thing uh or that little
that little boy girl whatever you guys
decide um
in that letter
say i'm gonna miss you
i'm gonna miss you i had so when she
told me we were pregnant i remember the
day she told me i remember how she told
me i got kind of scared and i got
freaked out and i looked at our bank
account
and also got pretty excited
take some kid you know the dodgers game
or whatever and watch the dodgers get
beat by the astros because the astros
are superior uh and uh
especially when they got trash cans on
the side right all those things right
all those things yeah
um and hey can i just tell you i'm sorry
thank you i've been there and i'm sorry
i'm sorry that your marriage is a mess
i'm sorry that your wife is hurting
sorry about miscarriage
sorry about there's just not a path
forward right now because we thought
we're gonna be here and now we're not we
don't know what's next i'm sorry about
all that stuff in there dude
yeah it's definitely uh something that i
did not
i didn't think it was gonna be this
difficult you know i just when you think
about babies you think it's how it's
done and it's easy and
i did not think it was gonna be this
difficult so it's definitely a little
and you dude your wife will see every 16
year old that accidentally got pregnant
and be like are you freaking kidding me
you know what i mean yeah trust me yeah
she'll she'll point out every accidental
pregnancy she'll point out every
you know [ __ ] at work that's just
getting yeah so-and-so got knocked off
it's so right it's it's a reminder to
her that she has failed and the path
through that
she clearly she hasn't failed anything
but the path through that is grief okay
right it's grief we had a picture of
what things were gonna be and that
picture's not happening yet it might and
we need to come up with a very
um very strong thick black line is a
finish line for how far we're going to
go
before we start everything
um otherwise you're going to find
yourself 200 000 in debt with 40
fertilized embryos and you don't know
what what to do next
right right so make a plan um and spend
some time grieving with her
these are your needs not hers and do not
try to fix her man just be with her this
is a hard hard season
hey
and if you do get pregnant in the next
two months three months six months nine
months please let me know and we will
celebrate you man i'll be high-fiving
you and if you don't get pregnant i'll
celebrate you too